calmar la sed en las fuentes de agua
pública una propuesta que se hace cada
vez más evidente en algunas ciudades de
europa como en venecia en donde las
autoridades han incentivado a los
turistas a que porten sus propios
recipientes y no compren botellas de
plástico de un solo uso
se puede gastar bastante sobre todo en
un viaje largo decenas y decenas y
decenas de botellas de plástico así que
intentamos llevar una con nosotros hemos
venido con cinco pero ya hemos perdido
una
y es que en esta ciudad italiana los
visitantes aportan entre el 28 y el 40
por ciento de la basura que se recoge en
temporadas turísticas según informes del
ayuntamiento de venecia la solución un
total de 190 fuentes de agua más o menos
una cada 100 metros lo que permite a los
turistas llenar sus botellas con el
preciado líquido y así ayudar al medio
ambiente y al interno de indispuesta
mapa aquí en este mapa hemos marcado las
fuentes de venecia las hemos marcado con
una gotita azul como pueden ver y eso es
también para dar a los turistas la idea
visual de que es una acción muy sencilla
de realizar
seguramente es sin duda de una forma de
producir menos residuos menos plástico
menos botellas por lo que significa
menos contaminación menos transporte y
menos de esos problemas que estamos
sintiendo en venecia por estos días
la propuesta llega justo cuando el
continente europeo atraviesa una ola de
calor sin precedentes y mientras varios
expertos ambientalistas señalan que más
medidas como ésta deben ser tomadas por
las autoridades locales para procurar
reducir la implacable huella del cambio
climático